[Music]
so last week I was back home in Hong
Kong and I spent a hundred bucks at a
dollar store
[Music]
now that I'm back here I thought it'd be
a lot more fun if I did a haul video
with one of my closest friends what do
you think of Dollar Stores I belongs in
a dollar store to get like really cheap
gifts for my friends and family so your
expectation for today is kind of like
pretty low very very low I spent $100 I
don't know why you would do that ready
for this okay I could buy them up into
like five categories first category
cutesy stuff oh my god you guys are so
cute isn't this a little too chichi a--
eraser pandas they love pandas they're
so cute it does work this you would not
be able to find at Family Dollar so I
would definitely Hong Kong just for
these cutest things just like you is
that a compliment she's goes like I
would told you want this in my house oh
I thought this was candy you can't you
didn't show this is false advertising
biscuit apple jam sandwich biscuit do
not buy this for the little kids because
they will eat it being your Rus this
really quality stuff in the Hong Kong
dollar store that's not a map you know
Hong Kong just makes some very fine
quality stuff squiggly lines how perfect
they are the canvas is just stuff
exquisite they get it you know that's us
9 but I feel like it's just like an
eight solid $1 slipper I went a little
crazy with slippers but either foldable
slippers oh you just do like that pull
the drawstring and there you happy
moving on third Paris can afford just by
walking with the oh my god I hate 10
bucks screw these guys all that gum out
there yeah I just got these guys out
there cute makes you actually want to
clean some dishes you can just hang this
on your sink so the little holes at the
bottom kind of help drain it out
Oh cotton bets and I see Oh yikes what
the heck is that it's like that was a
cheeseburger shampoo visor it keeps the
shampoo above your hairline would know
that this is I love this right here you
know I have so many different wigs oh
this is perfect
you just think of me all the time you're
such a thoughtful friend I appreciate
you okay it's fine does bizarre it's
just super cute that would say yes okay
beep beep bop boo we come in peace oh
[Music]
it's a pencil case where do these come
into play this is not good my ass oh wow
it does fit you that's why they're
disposable ladies only detergent only
for blood and vaginal discharge oh oh oh
oh oh on your underwear okay sorry I
thought you in a douche with this genius
[Music]
oh yeah should give us a tasty I can't
wait to eat these there are these two
sauces this is microwavable rice why is
it kind of scary to me you're gonna try
the pasta and the curry the curry is
really good we're microwavable rice this
is pretty good we're a dollar pocket
this is mmm wow this is so good oh my
god it's really good for a dollar that
Michelle say whoa I'd pay 30 bucks for
this just helps the bread cool and just
go show the stickers it's still like
pressed faces onto the little sausages
if I made like a lunchbox do this how
cute would that be I would be the cutest
thing I wish she made me
oh my god it's really hard
well that's I know maybe things that
I've never uses super liquidy is this
supposed to happen kill your wiping it
up it works I want to use it but yeah
lose my chemicals blended I give it a
b-plus actually not - whose shadow I
gots a contour I'm scared to try this on
my face but I look like a Greek
sculpture there's a no shadow gonna
sting ever I would love to put that on
my vanity say can I keep it you have
white hair I mean you don't because you
have a wig if you have like a single
strand or to kind of go like this Oh
cat's eye line tape so I try to put it
on it looks like a sticker as it feels
like a stick that's not for us that was
it that was all the stuff they've got
some pretty phenomenal stuff over there
your makeup was okay but everything else
hurt this is making wanna go to Hong
Kong I've always wanted to go there I'm
asleep and now and I definitely want to
go just for the dollar that's a wrap
yeah it's okay can I get my goodies not
good cuz I gotta go I just
[Music]